et pour évoquer cette audition de l'idée
raul tu nous sommes en direct avec
france 15 avr au blu médecin généraliste
membre de la société de pathologie
infectieuse langue française présidente
du conseil national professionnel des
maladies infectieuses et tropicales
bonsoir france 15ème rob lowe merci
d'être avec nous également en direct à
l'écouté poulat éditorialistes
cofondateur du monde moderne
bonsoir à vous également alexis poulain
didier rahout devant l'assemblée
nationale donc vous l'avez j'imagine
écouter enfin lié encore ça continue un
petit peu ce que déjà il vous a appris
quelque chose sur la gestion de la crise
alexis poulain il nous a confirmé en
fait cette gestion de crise calamiteuse
en fait par un ministre qui arrivait
dans le poste puisque rappelons le agnès
buzyn miss de la santé démissionner pour
faire la campagne des municipales à
paris donc en libérant arrive il est
évidemment comme le dit eric ciotti un
ministre sous influence entouré de ses
directeurs et de ses hauts
fonctionnaires qui vont l'influencer
donc il a simplement enfoncer le clou
didier raoult sur le manque de tests sur
les mauvais choix qui ont été faits le
fait de tout de suite
écoutez des conseillers qui visiblement
baignait dans le conflit d'intérêt pour
déconsidérer la queue rockin et le
protocole que raoult proposé est donc
vraiment ce qui a été je pense le le le
la marque de fabrique de la gestion de
crise par ce gouvernement c'est
l'amateurisme et c'est le fait d'avoir
refusé les tests d'emblée alors que ceux
ci auraient pu éviter le confinement
total qui va nous conduire à la crise
économique annoncé qui va nous exploser
à la figure en septembre
donc c'est vraiment simplement triste de
voir que ce grand infectiologues réputé
qui étaient là avec sa légion d'honneur
au revers de sa veste n'a pas été
écoutée à sa juste valeur a quitté
d'ailleurs ce conseil sanitaire en
voyant très bien que ça n'irait pas très
loin et puis il a eu raison de dénoncer
le monde de la recherche la façon dont
sont faites les choses aujourd'hui
il faut jeter un pavé dans la mare je
crois que ça suffit
il à dire encore une fois c'est un homme
de données ça ne sert à rien
d'extrapoler avec des algorithmes pour
faire croire à des modèles
il y à des données des malades qu'il
faut soigner il a aussi critiqué la
gestion de crise où les malades ont été
traités comme des cobayes et on aurait
pu sans doute évité ce nombre de morts
si on avait fait autrement alors par
refermer entendu la gestion de crise
mais je crois que c'est important que
cette commission aille à terme et qu'il
y en ait d'autres
au delà de du choix présidentiel d'avoir
une autre commission parce que les
responsables sont aujourd'hui aux
manettes et c'est pas une vendetta
personnelle de didier raoult par rapport
à un nombre de ses confrères fois qu'il
montre là il pointe du doigt un grave
dysfonctionnement de la santé en général
avec ce poids des lobbys qui est
insupportable et gilead on en reparlera
mais gilead risque donc d'être acheté
par astrazeneca qui va fournir ce vaccin
qui on a signé un protocole d'accord
avec ce laboratoire pour un vaccin qui
n'existe pas qui ne serait valable qu'un
an et voilà qu'on va dépenser des
milliards pour la recherche des millions
pour acheter un vaccin dont on ne
connaît rien c'est dire le poids des
lobbys c'est dire le danger pour notre
santé au niveau mondial d'avoir en fait
il ya un secteur celui de la santé aux
mains de simplement des profils et des
investisseurs plutôt que aux mains des
citoyens et des docteurs alors france 15
9 heures bleues il ya plusieurs idées un
résumé la part alexis poulain alors vous
avec d'autres médecin spécialisé en
maladies infectieuses il faut le
préciser vous alerter sur les propos
graves du docteur personne du professeur
peron plutôt proche justement de didier
raoul tu vous visez d'ailleurs dans une
tribune sans le citer le professeur
raoul tu on imagine que votre discours
sera un peu moins indulgent que celui
d'alexis poulain qu'est ce que vous lui
reprochez précisément à dire ajouté est
ce que il sait bien finalement pas
défendu mais enfin c'est vrai que ça
ressemblait parfois une défense devant
la commission de l'assemblée nationale
cet après midi alors que l'écouté avec
intérêts en audition javoukey pas appris
beaucoup plus que ce qu'on avait déjà
entendu et moi gentil pas là évidemment
corriger pour tout faire à lens
je pense que tout le monde peut avoir
une idée en médecine peut avoir une
intuition après
on sait tous trompés dans cette épidémie
et il faut avoir l'humilité de
reconnaître et là on a quand même des
données assez robuste de survie et roxy
pürro qui pour se dire que bavard il
faut sérieusement au délà question on
n'a peut-être pas il n'y a peut-être pas
le bénéfice qu'on pouvait en espérer
voilà donc je reste assez prudent parce
que je pense qu'il faut avoir toutes les
données
vraiment je tiens tes charmes a dit les
premières vécu il n'y avait pas de roue
comparateur s'est pas levée du grand
dôme iv alors on sera l'autre explique
que c'est plus le bras qu on peut
regarder des comparaisons mais pour
comparer des groupes il faut que ce soit
des tasses comparable et on n'a pas la
garantie
voilà je vois rester très prudent sur
toutes ces données il faudra beaucoup
d'humilité savoir que tout le monde
s'est trompé que c'est très facile de
faire un métier où la veille mais là il
faut surtout être humble et regarder les
choses très fidèlement possible
sereinement alors on va quand même
écouter l'avis du professeur période que
vous avez copieusement critiqué où il
évoque justement l'hydroxyde chloroquine
puisque c'était l'un des sujets du jour
un beau aussi l'audition du professeur
out vous propose d'écouter ce communiqué
là
prescription de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
aux patients atteints par l'aco vite 19
n'a pas fait la preuve de son efficacité
les études rigoureuses réalisés par des
équipes sans a priori au niveau
international ont toutes conclu sur
l'absence de bénéfices tandis que le
risque de décès liés à un mauvais usage
est lui parfaitement avérée le public
est en droit d'attendre de la part de
ces médecins de la sérénité dans la
communication des données médicales sans
tromperie ni démagogie alors les propos
sont durs france cazenave rob lowe vous
les trouvez grave g en accusateurs c'est
moi qui vous avez entendu la paire du
raclette répondions mais là il ya le
tout la forme on peut tout à fait ne pas
être d'accord
en matinée il faut qu'il y ait des
débats et d'ailleurs je crois que le
cabinet seura ou tout à l'heure il faut
qu'il y ait des débats or manquée la
forme et ne pas faire croire à des
familles que qui en avaient utilisé
lille-europe cycle rock'n'doc vous
souhaitez tout le monde
on invite à éviter 25 mars est
inamissible de tenir des propos pareils
c'est indécent ville invite toutes les
familles qui pleurent leurs morts
parce que rien ne permet d'affirmer à
alexis poulain quel est votre sentiment
didier raoult était très remonté
effectivement il dit que celui qui a
décidé d'interdire la chloroquine a fait
une grave erreur
quelle est votre réaction par rapport
aux élections c'est simplement pourquoi
aucune étude n'infirme ou ne confirme le
protocole qui fonctionne que ce soit la
part du dr house qui a sorti d'études
mais qui est critiquable au niveau
international où on a vu le fiasco du
land c'est tout là c'était carrément
catastrophique une publication soit
disant qu'ils mettaient fin au débat qui
était en fait un mensonge éhonté et une
protection totalement bidon de chiffres
qui n'existaient pas avec mad et des
données dont on ne savait pas d'où elles
venaient donc pourquoi tous les labos
quel qu'il soit gilead astrazeneca
sanofi et tous les autres ne finance pas
une étude mondiale où ils sont tous
d'accord pour dire voilà
faire ce protocole raoult on va le faire
dans les règles de l'art on va prendre
les trois mois qu'il faut et puis on
vous sortira des résultats qui seront
incontestables pourquoi cette étude
n'existe pas bien simplement parce que
chaque étude en fait est financé par des
gens qui ont intérêt à faire avancer
l'un ou l'autre des choix quand on parle
de gilead
on parle du rnd et vire qui coûte
extrêmement cher et qui ne marche pas
plus que hydroxy le rockeur aux kings
donc ça suffit pour quoi les labos ne se
met pas ensemble pour faire une étude
qui soit simplement la seule qui fasse
référence qu'ils soient incontestables
pour tous pour how comme pour ses
détracteurs
ça suffit enfin on joue avec la santé
des gens simplement parce que derrière
c'est quoi ces des lobbys d'intérêt pas
autre chose
je n'ai pas confiance dans les labos de
la big pharma alors certes ils sont des
médicaments mais aujourd'hui la majeure
partie de l'argent qui sortent des
profits qu'ils font c'est pour acheter
des petits labos qui font de la
recherche
eux ne font plus vraiment de rechercher
des start-up maintenant du biomédical
qui vont commencer à avoir des nouveaux
médicaments qui vont sortir ces
médicaments c'est plus peu que ce soit d
sanofi des gilead ou autres ils sont là
maintenant pour réduire les effectifs
pour réduire les coûts et pour cracher
du profit comme n'importe quelle boîte
comme n'importe quelle boîte
internationale et éviter en plus impôts
donc face à un moment pourquoi la santé
est romain de ces gens là qui n'ont pas
en fait le bien-être des populations à
coeur mais davantage le profit et
bien-être de leurs portefeuilles
d'actions france cazenave rob lowe c'est
vrai que c'est souvent revenus sains de
l'audition de didier rahout aujourd'hui
ces enjeux financiers d'ailleurs il s'en
est pris clairement au laboratoire
gilead les enjeux financiers du coc
vides sont d'un niveau que je n'ai
jamais
dans ma carrière est ce que vous
partagez au moins ça se passe au
diagnostic de 10 des résultats
alors moi je ne sais pas ce qu'il a vu
dans sa carrière ou pas donc me
permettrais pas de juger une fois encore
en revanche mais on y croit tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que de la
bonne recherche devrait être de la
recherche menée au niveau d'un état et
qui devraient être coordonnées mais bien
sûr ce serait l'idéal
si on pouvait n'avoir aucune
intervention de l'industrie
pharmaceutique dans la recherche
simplement d'y mettre de gros moyens
et puis je crois que ça demanderait
aussi d'avoir un coordination plus
efficace au niveau européen alors je
voudrais vous faire réagir également sur
une autre sortie de didier rahout
concernant justement la part de
politiques et la part de m soul tient
une véritable question qui s'est posée
pour moi cette question la santé
publique c'est 70 à 80% en politique eva
30% de sciences et de médecine et on a
eu l'impression un certain nombre de cas
que des décisions politiques que je
crois purement politique le confinement
le masse dans la rue ces décisions
politiques
il n'y a pas de données scientifiques
qui permettront jamais prouvé ça parce
que c'est des notion d'écosystème qui a
été déchargée sur des scientifiques et
des décisions médicales qui ont été
préemptés par le politique
et si on qu'elles lâchent vraiment d
accord donc je crois qu'il ya une vraie
réflexion sur le recueil la part du
politique
quelle est la part du médecin etc est la
part de scientifiques le scientifique
doit apporter de la connaissance
supplémentaires et sur une maladie
nouvelle c'est une connaissance qui ne
peut être que progressive et faut
organiser la mise en place et la
progression de la connaissance
les médecins doivent faire le métier de
médecin quatre soignés et les politiques
doivent organiser la société tesla santé
publique c'est toujours difficile parce
que la limite entre les uns et les
autres est toujours un peu complexe
alexis poulain la politique a pris trop
de place dans cette gestion de
l'épidémie de coronavirus oui
complètement ans à regarder
olivier ferrand n'attend même pas quand
on est les retours sur l'étude de
zélande 7 qui ne servent à rien pour
immédiatement interdire l'utilisation de
biberons koroki nous d'arrêter au moins
une expérimentation dans discovery
pourquoi faire ça et bien parce que
simplement ce protocole a va prendre
beaucoup de retard et que les millions
dédiés à la recherche vont aller du côté
du vaccin pouvant aller du côté des
lobbys qui ont gagné et c'est bien ça
tout le problème c'est qu'on est en
train de faire des choix qui sont des
choix politiques et non pas des choix
médicaux ou scientifique
et c'est ça qui devrait me pose des
questions à nous tous médecins citoyens
malades familles de malades
non mais mais qui décide et pourquoi
madame dizier pourquoi on n'est pas
capable d'organiser une recherche au
niveau national et au niveau européen
la santé n'est pas par exemple
évidemment du ressort de l'union
européenne pas il serait peut-être temps
de changer parce que les millions qu'on
va même être pour financer un vaccin
privé d'astrazeneca
ils vont servir à rien alors qu'on
pourrait les mettre dans la recherche de
long terme avec des chercheurs qui sont
subventionnées par l'état par les états
dans l'intérêt général
là on prend des millions à de l'impôt
pour financer des profits privés c'est
insupportable ce système de santé à
l'international et et même la crise du
corps d'un des bus ne remet pas du tout
ça en doute c'est à dire qu on est
totalement tributaire des labos qui
décident de délocaliser leur production
de médicaments là où c'est moins cher
qui décide de faire ce qu'il veut qu'ils
décident même du prix du médicament
quand astrazeneca dit qu'il va vendre à
prix coûtant son vaccin c'est bien lui
qui décide du prix de toute façon qu'ils
écoutent en est déjà là il faut un
profit donc on est mais prisonnier otage
de ses laboratoires qui décide pour tous
et les politiques qui sont extrêmement
faibles et qui finalement sont comme le
disait eric ciotti sous influence de ces
grands lobbys d'argent qui permettent
d'acheter et bien les décisions
politiques
france 15 9 rob lowe vous avez le même
diagnostic en tout cas là la politique a
pris trop de partout car dans cette
gestion de l'épidémie et c'est quelque
chose qu'on pourrait justement reproché
dans cette gestion alors là je me
garderai bien de ce genre de commentaire
c'est comme ce raout dit il ya eu 3 310%
et de politiques et 30 au centre
scientifique bah voilà sur quoi soit
comment il fait ses calculs moi je n'ai
pas de méthode de calcul
je pense que le politique on en a besoin
quoi qu'il arrive on a besoin d'une
coordination
il faut que quelqu'un décide gouverner
c'est quand même anticiper c'est prévoir
donc il faut bien que
qu'un prenne des décisions et c'est
tellement facile après de se dire
c'était pas la bonne décision au bon
moment j'ai pas la compétence pour juger
ce qu'ont fait les politiques
alors oui aujourd'hui les décisions une
décision à prendre c'est de briser les
chaînes avec ses labos et de dire
écoutez cette recherche nous avons les
moyens de la financer
le coc vide a totalement bouleversé la
donne c'est la première pandémie de
cette échelle-là convives au 21e siècle
il va falloir réfléchir parce que c'est
pas la dernière
et je sais pas comment vous vous
travaillez en tant que médecin avec les
laboratoires si vous avez déjà participé
à des séminaires ou vous à payer des
voyages ou des choses comme ça vous
devez déclarer d'ailleurs un site qui
permet de voir si les médecins seront
touchés les médecins des laboratoires et
on a avancé
justement parce qu'il y avait déjà
beaucoup trop d'opacité dans ce domaine
là et je crois qu'il faut aller encore
plus loin pour libérer la recherche de
des enjeux d'argent alors regarde
pendant justement de cette gestion de
l'épidémie entre science et politique
on l'a vu c'est le conseil scientifique
je voudrais qu'on écoute tout d'abord
l'avis du professeur hauteur sur ce
conseil scientifique vous demandez
pourquoi je suis pas resté dans ce
conseil scientifique c'est parce que je
considérais que c'était pas un conseil
scientifique et que je ne fais pas je le
fais pas de présence pas le temps et
donc les gens qui étaient là n'était pas
je sais ce que c'est un conseil
scientifique moi j'ai un conseil
scientifique pour la chaussure qui fait
rêver le monde entier de qualité c'est
que des stars de leur domaine
c'est pas ça c'est un conseil
scientifique pour moi c'était pour de
les conseils scientifiques déterminer
quels étaient les projets scientifiques
ce n'était pas à nous de réfléchir sur
le confinement ou son truc personne ne
sait répondre à ça donc les discussions
qu'elle avait dans ce conseil
scientifique ne me concernait pas
françoise improbable au quel est le
regard que vous portez sur le rôle qu'a
joué le conseil scientifique dans toute
cette gestion de crise on a été quand
même bien content d'avoir toutes nos
instances comme le haut conseil de la
santé publique par qu'on achète
la dgs qui nous ont fait des
recommandations dont on avait bien
besoin
j'aimerais vraiment saluer le travail du
haut conseil de la santé publique pour
ce qui concerne le conseil scientifique
ce n'est pas nous qui l'avons choisi il
a été choisi parmi des experts qui
avaient une certaine notoriété et qui
avaient été reconnus pour leurs
compétences
moi je ne peux que regretter que didier
rahout n'y soit pas resté il aurait
certainement enrichir les débats et je
pense que la politique de la chaise vide
c'est toujours un peu de moins en ces
situations alexis poulain sur ce rôle là
on se souvienne fait le conseil
scientifique est préconisé voilà l'arrêt
de l'école la reprise après de l'école
les élections également votre regard sur
son rôle c'est extrêmement difficile
évidemment d'orienter le choix d'une
politique sachant qu'on engage sa
responsabilité et donc la responsabilité
de donner lui enfin loin du ministre des
responsables après fonctionnel donc
c'est un choix complexes le problème
c'est la sélection évidemment la
composition de ce conseil scientifique
et pour didier raoult c'est habile
finalement de n'y être pas allé parce
qu'il ne s'en cache pas il n'engage pas
sa responsabilité donc pour lui c'est
évidemment il peut jouer les chevaliers
blancs après après coup devant moi j'ai
dit de mon côté a marseille c'est comme
ça qu'il faut faire mais je n'ai pas
débattu parce que c'était une perte de
temps donc de facto il se
déresponsabilise ce que j'essaye de
faire d'ailleurs à peu près tous les
responsables de cette crise de cette
gestion de crise
mais lui l'a fait de manière prompte et
pendant je n'irai pas parce que je sais
que de toute façon on va s'engager vers
quelque chose dont on ne sait pas il l'a
dit d'ailleurs c'est ce virus on ne
connaît pas c'est la recherche qui va
faire qu'on va le connaître petit à
petit beaucoup de choses ont été dites
son protocole bien j'attends que une
étude met fin à tous les débats on n'a
pas encore entre les mains cette étude
mais pour lui la politique de la chaise
vide c'était évidemment la plus facile
de manière politique est là il a été
très politique
malgré ce qu'il peut dire on va terminer
sur un autre sujet qui a été abordé
entre autres un pascal a eu de nombreux
les tests qui n'ont pas été assez
généralisé ce grand professeur
marseillais écoutez je ne suis pas
d'accord avec la décision qui a été
prise de ne pas généraliser les tests
dès le début de mars
l'om est à recommander de tester tous
les gens qui étaient suspects ou
contacter pour locaux vides 19 il y
avait les moyens dans ce pays de le
faire un des problèmes de fond ici c'est
ce que ce que les gens appellent un
centre national de référence lors il
pouvait pas y avoir de centre national
de référence pour ce conte à virus
puisqu'il n'existait pas non je vois pas
comment on aurait pu désigner un
ensemble de références pour ça il ya des
gens qui ont dit c'est nous la référence
donc il ya une part d'intoxication et
c'est moi qui ai expliqué excuses au
président pour la première fois et qui
lui ai redit vous savez la pcr c'est
très simple et tout le monde peut faire
et donc c'est pendant tout ce temps on
n'a pas dit la vérité
c'est un examen et que s'annonce un
banal tout le monde est capable de faire
en france 15 9 à rob lowe alexis paulhan
j'imagine que vous êtes d'accord il
fallait généraliser les tests je
m'attends à être d'abord à la
l'infectiologue que vous êtes je ne sais
pas ce que ça aurait donné tout ce que
je sais c'est qu'au moment où les tests
n'étaient pas tous disponibles et
surtout ont manqué parce que ça il faut
bien le dire ont manqué découvrions des
liens dans l'allier chui non ils ont
bien public et le fait qu'ils avaient
utilisé des découvrions qui venaient
d'un peu partout
donc on manquait surtout des aiguillons
donc là c'est pas la technique qui nous
manquait c'est le matériel pour faire le
prélèvement à ce moment là effectivement
les médecins se sont un peu
responsabiliser en se disant il vaut
mieux les garder pour les patients pour
qui c'est indispensable de préciser le
diagnostic parce que les autres ça veut
pas dire qu'on ne faisait rien ça veut
dire qu'on leur disait cliniquement
parce qu'on vous a examiné on vous a
interrogé il est hautement probable que
vous soyez atteindre coronavirus donc
restez chez vous et confiné vous c'était
ça le message qui nous paraissait le
plus important de tests pas test ça
n'aurait pas changé grand chose sur la
prise en charge à ce moment là
maintenant on peut toujours dire si on
avait testé si on avait dit aux gens
effectivement vous êtes positif ça les
aurait peut-être inciter à mieux
s'isoler
c'est possible mais ça personne ne le
sait personne en effet quand même en
allemagne avec
beaucoup de succès et lexie poulain sur
ces tests évidemment tous les pays qui
ont eu la gestion la plus juste de cette
crise pas la moins une catastrophique
qui nous n'a pas conduit au confinement
total comme on l'a eu en france aux
privilégiés les tests des tests massif
qui permettait de finir qu'ils étaient
porteurs du virus et et pouvait infecter
d'autres personnes ou qui pouvait
ressortir ou aller dans des structures
plus légères de prise en charge
on a manqué de tout en france les
personnels soignants en première ligne
ont manqué de tous les échos villon
n'était pas là les masques n'était pas
là les tests n'étaient pas là quand les
vétérinaires dit écoutez on a les
produits qui sont là on peut faire il
faudrait généraliser les tests
personne ne répond et la planification
le fait que à un moment vous avez un
président qui dit qu'on est en guerre et
qui ne sait rien en fait pour mettre le
pays en ordre de bataille pour bien
répondre à la menace qui était celle du
virus
c'était vraiment nécessaire en anglais
ou en bas se débrouiller et puis de la
com comme d'habitude donc on monte un
hôpital de campagne mais on n'organise
pas une filière de tests qu'il aurait
plus justement déceler au plus tôt les
gens qui étaient porteurs de ce virus
est organisé un confinement non pas
globale général mais un confinement
cibler les clusters c'était un bon début
mais ils n'ont pas été fait correctement
puisqu'on avait pas de test donc on a et
bien simplement choisi la pire des
solutions le confinement qui nous
conduit à la pire des crises économiques
je n'ai jamais vu donc voilà c'est
normal que didier raoult dit ça et quand
vous avez de l'autre côté
devant cette même commission denquête de
professeurs salomon qui dit que quand
lolness par des tests et ce n'était pas
du tout pour la france puisque l'on n'a
pas besoin de faire de test mais on est
où on est où moi je préfère écouter rare
que précieux de salomon parce que là on
est vraiment dans un exemple typique du
scientifique qui fait de la politique et
de la très mauvaise politique merci à
tous les deux françois cazenave rob lowe
et alexis poulain merci d'avoir été avec
nous pour décrypter cette audition de
didier raoul qui va bientôt s'achever
devant la commission de l'assemblée
nationale dans